und zwar bin ich ich mache es ganz kurz
bei war rot reiß la rosa skills und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge mine
klafter onliner und spielen heute ändern
games zum ersten mal seit einer sehr
sehr sehr sehr lange zeit ich weiß gar
nicht wann ich zum letzten mal ender
games let's play tourismus eine ewigkeit
her sein locker mehrere monate aber
heute ist es wieder soweit denn ich hab
mir gedacht die bringen ein bisschen
abwechslung 1 und spüren bisschen ändern
games und ich hab euch heute zwei dinge
zu berichten
eine sache die sehr erfreulich ist und
eine andere sache die noch viel viel
viel viel viel viel mehr erforderlich
ist er froh so deutsches schwer
erfreulicher ist ein paar von euch
werden es vielleicht schon mitbekommen
haben
auf twitter worum es geht und event
jetzt denke ich weiss nicht aber ihr die
swiss light leise damit die anderen auch
erfahren können sie können es nicht
erfahren wenn er sagt so ok hier hinten
ist noch eine kiste 3ds sehr gute zeit
für ein schwert 8 ist diese kakaobohnen
ja okay die erste nachricht leute ist
die folgende ich habe heute meine letzte
klausur geschrieben und damit ist das
semester für mich weitestgehend vorbei
ich möchte ich an der stelle noch mal
entschuldigen dass in den letzten tagen
nicht so super regelmäßig videos kam ich
war einfach in klausuren stress und ja
wenn man halt jetzt man einen tag oder
so für die uni richtig intensiv lernen
muss und ein video machen kann dann sag
ich mir halt auch okay geht jetzt
erstmal juni kurz vor weil ein tag
videomacher hoffentlich alltag ein video
zu machen dass hoffentlich keine
riesending für euch kommt was
funktioniert funktioniert ok wollen wir
erstmal hier ab das ist die erste sache
das heißt dass ab jetzt wieder jeden tag
videos kommen werden und dazu auch noch
auf den anderen plattformen besser
machen diesen sommer aber dazu möchte
jetzt nicht zu viel verraten ich sag mal
so viel
haltet diesen sommer mal die augen nach
tweets offen
okay was bist du für ein gegenstand
alles klar ein blockbuster schippen der
luft gut solche dinge passieren aber
auch mal im echten leben so wie es unser
dem schwert wir haben die leder fest da
hinten ist
ich habe so lange kein ende gespielt ich
habe nicht wirklich ein überblick über
die kids ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich mit
abholen kaum und im wasser kann vor
allem nicht so viel machen weil er
wahrscheinlich kein gerüst wieder gesamt
ist ja sehr gut das heißt dann habe ich
schon
und vielleicht nehmen wir pilawa habe
ich aber schon hab ich mein lover einmal
auf die 3 den kompass neu aber auch noch
da unten so da könnte ich noch im wasser
einmal mitnehmen so gut das ist die
erste sache leute wie gesagt ich habe
jetzt mehr zeit die zweite sache ist die
die noch viel erfreulicher ist und noch
mehr wahrscheinlich auch für euch eine
positive überraschung ist und zwar bin
ich ich mache es ganz kurz
bei war rot 3 dabei was haltet ihr davon
ist es nicht super ich bin bei 3 dabei
ist hat geklappt ich bin für luca
reingekommen da könnte ich noch mal beim
lieben luca bedanken der ja dann nicht
dabei sein kann
dieses jahr ich mache das einfach mal so
oft keine ahnung macht nicht viel sinn
denn nicht dabei sein kann und deswegen
gesagt hat ja könnt ihr es reinholen für
wen
für mich und die leute haben gesagt bzw
gps organisiert ja okay weil auch noch
wie max und wenn gesagt haben jahres
kate der ist kein keinen hohen zaun den
kammern reinholen
so hat geklappt leute jetzt bin ich mal
drei dünne es ist noch nicht ganz
geschafft mit wem ich aber thema das
weiß ich ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht
ich wollte mit den themen aber werde ich
mit wenig ihnen können
das ist die frage ferner wollte ich auch
noch mit tom von enya team mit dem
klappt es aber höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht
und dann wollte ich noch mit benthin auf
bands antwort warte ich noch mal gucken
was der benni boy dazu sagt
ob der mit es team kann ist wäre
eigentlich gut für ihn oder es wäre gut
für ihn als würde ich ihm einen vorteil
bringen
das werde ich ganz neues so wir
verstehen uns auch privat ganz gut wenn
und ich dann zusammen so im team wir
sind ja auch beide ein bisschen stein
alte säcke wo alter schwede
protestpausen hallo du baroque ihn
erstaunt walter ender games macht nicht
so fertigt das ist so ein brutales
action spiel
es ist richtig brutal bringt leute zu
böse dinge zu tun
okay gut so der nächste gegner ist hier
schreibt mir mal ein kommentar ist ein
ganz neues oder dass ich jetzt doch bei
war oder bei sein kann
nachdem ich beim letzten mal hatte ich
schon probiert das habe ich schon mal im
video erzählt letztes jahr mal nicht
damit da hat es nicht geklappt
dieses jahr hat es geklappt was ist wohl
das hat geklappt und ich bin super super
super super happy darüber freue mich
richtig und ich glaube es wird gab es
wird richtig heiß und ich werde mich
auch gut darauf vorbereiten könnt ihr
euch darauf verlassen ich habe mir schon
gedanken gemacht die zugegebenermaßen
bisschen krank und übertrieben sind und
auf live schließen lassen aber ich wäre
jetzt wenn ich einmal dabei bin
alle chancen alle in der alle
möglichkeiten nutzen die man zur
verfügung stehen um nicht gescheit
darauf vorzubereiten
und ich weiß wo ist auch ein bisschen
glück gerade in der ersten runde da ich
meine in der ersten runde als was mal
was jetzt erste runde direkt nach dem
start in der ersten folge geht es halt
einfach nur unglück also da hängt nur
davon ab wer läuft hinter einem her hat
der zufällig aus der mitte ein
holzschwert gezogen oder hat er sich
schnell ein holzschwert kräften können
die erste folge ist glück die zweite
dritte vielleicht auch ein bisschen
glück aber auch dann ist es schon ein
bisschen mehr skill und planung und da
kann man auch mehr machen mit
vorbereitung und ihr könnt sicher sein
dass ich mich gut vorbereiten werde für
euch dass ich mir auch noch ein team
partner suchen werde
der cool ist vielleicht nicht das macht
dann machen wir vielleicht dann fange
ich vielleicht mal cartel den vielleicht
auch ganz cool
karmann haben den typ denn den typen
sage ich den hut
das sind so meine momentane überlegung
zu dem thema ich kann euch auch noch
erzählen dass nachher also wenn ich das
video aufgenommen habe beziehungsweise
eineinhalb stunden da muss mich auch
noch richtig beeilen ich so eine kleine
schiffsrundfahrt machen werde vielleicht
post sich davon ein bild auf instagram
das wird richtig meister war so ein
schiff gemietet also relativ viele leute
nicht youtube mannis teil sondern
einfach viele viele leute fahren dann
nachher bislang mit rom schippern
das liegt ihr fahrzeug jetzt nicht
gebrauchen vielleicht kann ich euch
daher was zeigen so was mal gucken
das ist eines richters in zwei sessions
okay dann habe ich mir einfach mal rein
sagt direkt in den kopf gucken 214 suite
und der nächste gegner ist so und so
viel blöcke entfernt was machen mit ich
weiß es nicht ich hab ich sollte
vielleicht mal über seine kutte mit
abwarten bevor ich mich dass herr
einstürze aber dann auch wieder nicht
oh ja junge übertreibt ein leben alter
ist der kasse gibt hajo jung ist der
krasse crypt junge was ich machen gegen
den halter machen
nein alte über drei was hatte der funk
geht man aber richtig gut gespielt von
ihm aber das war es auch schon das war
der letzte gegner okay das war's für
heute leute wie gesagt für mich geht's
gleich weiter ich wollte euch das
nochmal erzählen
ender games mit ein bisschen rein führen
aber platz zwei war jetzt auch nicht so
schlecht ich hoffe euch hat das heutige
video gefallen und ihr könnt mit den
infos wasser anfangen
gerne auch noch weitere team vorschläge
an die ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht habe
die kommentare
wir sind bei der nächsten folge wieder
rein macht rudow